Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today. Adam Rogers, who's a senior tech correspondent
at Insider and also author of the book Full
Spectrum. One of his recent articles is going
to be the catalyst for a conversation today
called Sure. Twitter and Facebook have deepened
polarization, just not in the way you think.
Adam, really great having you on today. Appreciate
your time.
Speaker 4: Oh, thanks for having me. I appreciate
it.
Speaker 1: So okay, I mean, let's let's kind
of go right to the punch line and then maybe
we'll work backwards from there. So it's common
to think social media has made polarization
worse. I think there's a number of ways that
people would assume that that's the case.
Filter bubbles and echo chambers probably
is one. And, you know, we can kind of list
others. What is the way in which you believe
social media platforms have deepened American
political polarization?
Speaker 4: Well, I'll tell you a couple of
things that that surprised me in the reporting
for this, and this is why I wanted to do the
story. The first thing is that while I think
I would have said before I started calling
people that the problem was an echo chamber,
a filter bubble, epistemic closure, right.
Was that, oh, we get on social media and then
we we somehow in some way tend to associate
with people who have the same political views
as we do and then maybe the same cultural
views as we do. And we don't hear anything
outside that. And I think that was fairly
commonly accepted. It turns out that among
social scientists actually not the case. Social
scientists have not found evidence for that.
And as one of them said to me, like, there's
there are worse echo chambers in real life,
you know, IRL, we tend to assert that way
and we don't turn into a political freak show,
you know, real life particularly. So if it's
not filter bubbles, it's not an echo chamber.
I would have said, oh, well, obviously it's
the reverse, right? You would say, oh, it's,
it's that you we go online and then we're
exposed to like repugnant views or views that
are repugnant to us. And we think, oh, those,
that, that guy is terrible. Like, I don't
want anything to do with whatever that person
is saying and anything that they believe in,
any of the stuff that they have in the background
of their, you know, chat window or whatever.
But that doesn't happen either when you actually
do tests. When researchers do tests on this,
people don't experience those kinds of feelings.
And we can talk about some of the studies,
say, in those experiences. So the question
then is what happens if we accept that polarization
is increasing? And that does seem to be true,
and if we accept the polarization is something
that's kind of independent of like, no, some
one political group actually is saying repugnant
things, like objectively repugnant things.
And if we accept that there are things that
that are weirdly politicized, which shouldn't
be political, and you and I might disagree
about what those things are, but you could
say something like, how does something like
climate change become political? How does
something like what car you drive? Or What
if you drive a car or what your favorite drink
is, whether it's alcoholic or not? How did
those things become political or polarizing?
And yet they do. So okay, that's a long run
up by way of saying that this is a researcher.
He's a computational social scientist. And
Pedro Kornberg, he's also trained as a physicist
and he's interested in complexity theory.
So the way that small things turn into big
things, basically, and what he says is if
you if you model digitally people in a large
social network, all it takes is really two
conditions to get real serious bad polarization.
All you have to do, first of all, is make
sure that people are connecting with with
non-local connections. So that means strangers,
people at a distance, people they wouldn't
ordinarily connect with distant from themselves,
both in terms of their demographic characteristics
and also literally like geographic distance.
And then you you kind of turn up our tendency
to distrust things that are unfamiliar to
us or the positive way to say that is trust
things that are familiar. All you have to
do is make those two dials happen and you
start to see the people, the little digital
sim, the sims inside this world begin to polarize
on things that are not just political, but
things that are cultural as well, what researchers
call affective polarization, very different
than ideological polarization or red blue
divide. This is stuff like, you know, if you
drive an F-150 or a Prius, things that are
choices that have political components but
are not themselves political choices, if you
see what I mean. And that kind of that affected
polarization and the demonization, the attendant
demonization of people who are not in your
effectively polarized group are the things
that researchers worry the most about.
Speaker 1: It seems that context must matter
to some degree, though, because there are
situations that people find themselves in
where they encounter those who at least exist
generally in very disparate places. They maybe
come together for a conference or for travel
or whatever the case may be. So you can you
can kind of make that a reality and you can
kind of put these components together and
they don't seem to explode in the same way
that often takes place on social media. Is
that something about the disinhibited context
of social media? That maybe is an additional
factor?
Speaker 4: Yeah, so that's a really good point.
All of us have had the experience of being
of having a perfectly pleasant meal with somebody
whose political views you find repugnant.
Obviously, that has its limits. If there's
somebody who wants to, you know, put you in
a camp, maybe you want to be sitting at the
same. Dinner table with them. But but you
see what I mean? Yes. So, yes, that context
matters a lot. And and there is the factor
that social media has an anonymizing effect.
Even if you have your real identity on there,
you're at a distance. It's a little like just
shouting at a television screen and the television
screen shouts back, you know? But there's
also the fact of the way the social networks
themselves work. These are these are, by and
large, depending on what you're on, what you're
using for profit networks. And what they depend
on is our attention and engagement because
they're trying to use our identities to sell
ads against. And so in addition to the factors
that TOTENBERG came up with, like how how
how does polarization happen in groups who
are exposed to each other in these particular
network with these particular kinds of network
effects? The social networks themselves turn
up their own dial for linking our identities
to our posts. So they ask, you know, who you
are essentially with everything that you look
at and everything that you post and then privileging
the loudest voices because those get the most
engagement and those tend to be the most extreme.
So, you know, again, we've all had the experience
of tootling along on Twitter or on Facebook
and then seeing something that was just astonishingly
terrible. Right. And your first instinct is
to want to be like, that's astonishingly terrible,
which plays right into the way the economics
of this thing work. And that increases polarization.
Right. And it increases our our sense that
everything that we're doing has a political
component.
Speaker 1: There are some like, for example,
Jonathan Haidt comes to mind, who has a sort
of maybe different diagnosis for what's going
on than you. But one of his suggestions is
you can have an anonymous handle on social
media, but the platform should know exactly
who you are. So like, for example, if I want
to operate on Twitter as, you know, anonymous
elephant to six, five, five, I can do that.
But when I create the account, I have to provide
Twitter with my driver's license or whatever,
proving that I really am who I say I am, and
that that would reduce the disinhibited nature
of social media to some degree. Do you agree
with that?
Speaker 4: Yeah. I have the. There's a Hemingway
line isn't it pretty to think so. I mean there.
First of all, I have concerns. Look, I'm not
as much of an expert as Jonathan is, but I
have some concerns about having identity be
an escrow in these for these for profit companies
as well. I don't I don't think that they're
trusted actors here. I would say that there
are. The Internet could have gone a very different
way in the mid 2000s, let's say. Right, where
the companies that turned into ad agencies
effectively and could have instead said we
are going to first of all, create a way that
to build identity into the base layer of the
Internet in the same way that like the Usenet
and email were built into the base layer of
the internet. We forget, I think, that Twitter
and Facebook and Google or websites, they're
fundamentally they're just websites. They're
huge, they're complicated. They're they're
vast, they're transnational, but they're just
websites. And what, what, what the people
who designed and built the Internet chose
not to do because they chose a more profit
oriented motive was not was to not build identity
into that base layer, to not build ways for
all of us to be able to control our own identity
and our own self-expression on the Internet.
And this is I sound a I've gone I've gone
very like boing boing on this. I think to
to say anything like what was what was supposed
to happen was that we were supposed to have
tools to make it easy to have a website, an
RSS feed. And if you want to have a a what
we used to call a blog and you now might call
a substack or medium or whatever, if you want
to have that, you can have that if you want
to sell stuff from your own little shop. Here
are some. Here's machinery where you can do
that retailing and fulfillment. But instead
we've seen it all of that stuff to these big
transnational companies. So, you know, so
I'm not sure that they're they are not who
I would trust to to be the arbiters, as we've
seen, to be good arbiter, good faith, arbiters
of political or other kinds of conversation
online. Although and so I'll I'll contradict
myself just very briefly and say the the I
think another experience that has become shared
in common is we might all have small, you
know, chat groups, right? Like group chats
or small groups that where you're in the DMS
on Twitter or invitation only, very tightly
moderated groups on Facebook, those kind of
smaller groups, sometimes group by affinity,
sometimes group by social connections that
are not on the Internet, sometimes that are
those become very positive. Those are those
are where my meaningful social connections
are at this point, in a way. And sometimes
they're orbited through those, through the
big social networks, through Twitter or through
Facebook or whatever. And sometimes they're
not. But but because of their size and because
they are, they are more tightly controlled,
not for for like affective ideological engagement,
but for some kind of emotional engagement
that's more meaningful. They tend to be more
positive spaces.
Speaker 1: When it comes to you mentioned
these these companies platforms, websites
as the arbiters here, it seems pretty clear
at this point that the platforms generally
benefit from the entire way that they have
operated, including boosting the voices that
as you talk about, increase the polarization,
loud voices, etc., we kind of understand that.
Is it fair to say that because of that, they
simply can't be counted on to try to work
on this problem? Is it that flat out or are
there ways to incentivize Facebook and Twitter
or whoever to actually try to fix this problem
rather than profit from it?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I don't know. That's that's
such a good question. And we see it going
on right now. I mean, that's the that's at
one of at the heart of what is happening with
Elon Musk. And Twitter, for example, is is
is he's, you know, clearly interested in in
in elevating voices from the right. He's engaging
with them himself. And so the question is,
will, like, how do you deal with that if you
know that a lot of those voices are also,
you know, trolls are also going to going to
potentially hurt people, you know, send out
sort of stochastic terrorism against trans
people or against Jews or against all the
people who sort of are are the, like targets
of the day. Yes, horribly so. And and so what
are we so the response to that has been like
essentially, weirdly to me, let the market
deal with it. Right. Well, he's going to lose
all his advertisers if he does that. That's
sort of our response. And that may happen.
Right. That could or the advertisers could
then pressure him and say, you can't do that
or we won't advertise. So it becomes the what
we trust as a society is that the the same
profit motives that got us here will get us
out. And, you know, that's the thing that
we could all perhaps be polarized online about
whether we believe will happen or not.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I guess I would say.
Speaker 4: Just I'm.
Speaker 1: Depressed. I don't have solid evidence
to think that that's exactly the way it would
work absent some kind of countervailing force.
But probably a conversation for for for the
next conversation. We've been speaking with
Adam Rodgers, who's a senior tech correspondent
at Insider, also author of the book Full Spectrum.
And we're going to link to the article that's
been the source for today's conversation.
Adam, really appreciate your time today. Thank
you.
Speaker 4: My pleasure. Thanks for having
me